just a little over four months after the
New York City mayor's office celebrated
immigrant Heritage week the leader of
the Big Apple seems to have changed his
tune on foreigners coming to his City
full support and let me tell you
something New Yorkers
never in my life have I had a problem
that I did not see and ended to
I don't see an ending to this
this issue
will destroy New York City
destroy New York City we're getting 10
000 migrants a month
one time we were just getting Venezuela
now we can Ecuador now again Russian
speaking coming through Mexico now we're
getting Western Africa now we're getting
people from all over the globe have made
their minds up that they're going to
come through the southern part of the
border and come into New York City
and everyone is saying it's New York
City's problem
every community in this city is going to
be impacted we had a 12 billion dollar
deficit that we're going to have to cut
every service in this city is going to
be impacted
Ann Coulter is that you
president Trump no that's not president
Trump that guy is way more
anti-immigration than president Trump
liberal Democrat mayor Eric Adams says
the current levels of immigration stand
to destroy New York City
and he's right
the greatest predictor of opposition to
mass migration contrary to what the
liberal media will tell you is not race
it's not class it's not even political
party the greatest predictor of
opposition to mass migration is
proximity to the consequences of mass
migration which is always and inevitably
harmful to political communities as
Statesmen and political philosophers
have observed for millennia the proof
Adams himself who just a few months ago
was still Towing the liberal line on
Sanctuary cities all are welcome here
diversity is our strength but now he's
discovered that those ridiculous slogans
are connected to real events
those real events are really occurring
and they're harming everyone involved so
now finally he's motivated to consider
maybe trying to do something to stop it
that's thanks to Republican Governors
like Greg Abbott and Ron DeSantis who
started sending those busloads of
illegal aliens up to the blue cities and
who we can only hope will keep the buses
coming I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
foreign
with a barely reanimated corpse in the
White House CBS is finally asking the
awkward question to Kamala Harris are
you ready to be president we'll get into
what that means in just a moment first
though speaking of the breakdown of
political order not just in New York but
all around the country Mike Huckabee
just got into a hot water oh boy all the
left-wing opposition groups they were
sending this clip around this was on
Governor Huckabee's excellent show
Huckabee
on which he said that if the legal
shenanigans that the Liberals are trying
right now to keep Trump off the ballot
if they
stop Trump
from winning the election then this will
be the last election decided by ballots
rather than bullets
do you know how political opponents to
those in power are dealt with in third
world dictatorships banana republics and
communist regimes well it's simple the
people in power use their police
agencies to arrest their opponents for
made-up crimes in an attempt to
discredit them bankrupt them imprison
them Exile them are all of the above
and if you're not paying attention you
may not realize that Joe Biden is using
exactly those tactics to make sure that
Donald Trump is not his opponent in
2024. here's the problem if these
tactics end up working to keep Trump
from winning or even running in 2024 it
is going to be the last American
election that will be decided by ballots
rather than bullets
there it is it's he's threatening he's
another insurrectionist we got to throw
Mike Huckabee in prison for 20 years
Mike Huckabee said nothing wrong every
single thing Mike Huckabee just said Is
Right
regardless of even what happens in the
election and how you interpret it
if
the legal mechanisms that the Liberals
are trying to use which are really
illegal mechanisms if they succeeded
taking Trump off the ballot in certain
places then the likelihood of civil war
is much higher the last time that we had
a president elected not being on the
ballot in a number of states was
immediately before the Civil War that's
just an historical fact
he's not saying if Trump loses the
election fair and square then the next
elections can be decided by bullets
rather than ballots he's saying if these
unfair often illegal operations that the
Liberals are trying if those succeed
then you're gonna have a breakdown of
the Electoral order that's obviously
true it's it's even true
if the the Liberals exert this kind of
power and keep the conservative from
having a fair shake at being elected
even then even if the conservatives do
nothing
and they sit at home on their hands it
will nevertheless remain true that the
future elections will be decided by
bullets rather than ballots because the
the bullets will be in the guns pointed
by the state at the people who want to
challenge the regime if there is no
longer to be any real political
opposition permitted in the United
States if every time an actual
opposition leader tries to run he gets
shut down because the the Liberals won't
even let him be placed on the ballot
then that means that our elections are
decided by bullets rather than ballots
because they're they're decided by the
implicit coercive force of the state of
the regime ABS as is often the case with
Mike Huckabee what he's saying is
obviously obviously true and the
Liberals are pursuing that strategy do
not
confuse yourself don't think it's
hyperbole or that we're all paranoid
with tinfoil hats the Liberals are
explicitly trying to keep Trump off the
ballot there's a group I teased this a
couple days ago a group in Colorado
trying to say that the 14th Amendment
is sufficient to remove Trump from the
2024 ballot this is Citizens for
responsibility and ethics based in
Washington DC Group filed a lawsuit on
Wednesday on behalf of several Colorado
voters to keep Trump off the ballot
because here's why section three of the
14th Amendment
says that public officials are not
eligible to hold office if they quote
engaged in Insurrection or Rebellion
against the United States
now
Trump for all of the ridiculous charges
that have been thrown at him in New York
and DC and Georgia and Florida
none of those charges is for
insurrection
obviously not it's absurd
even if that were the case I don't see
any evidence that that fact alone would
preclude a man from running for
president the mere suggestion that he
were an insurrectionist I mean if that
if that were sufficient then they could
do it to stop Donald Trump right now
but what this really represents is a
criminalization of politics
I've pointed out that when the Liberals
accuse conservatives of being
authoritarian it's it's an absurd claim
conservatives meekly suggest that maybe
we return to the social mores of 2015
and we're told that we're knuckle
dragging authoritarian we're basically
the Taliban or something but let's say
that the authoritarian accusation were
Fair which it is not if it were Fair it
would still be preferable to what the
Liberals are offering which is
totalitarianism
authoritarianism is when the government
says hey you can't do weird stuff in the
street you've gotta you've gotta stop
letting your freak flag fly on Main
Street but what you do in your private
life is not any of our concern what the
totalitarians say is even your private
life
needs to be dictated by us
it's a big difference authoritarian
regimes
will often allow a lot of space in the
culture in local communities for people
to basically do whatever they want it
just can't infringe on National cohesion
and unity
totalitarian regimes encourage kids to
rat on their parents like is happening
now a totalitarian regimes insist on the
party Orthodoxy in the education system
and in the media and in the press and in
the Civic associations and in either the
local bowling league in every in every
facet of society the propaganda and the
party line has to permeate and if you
question it in any way you'll be
ostracized you'll be kicked out of the
Public Square which today is called
de-platforming on social media you'll be
threatened with legal action you'll be
thrown in the can for protesting there
you have it we've seen this time and
time again
that is a totalitarian system and what
it what it comes down to is in the name
of liberalism
they say that we can't have any
alternatives to liberalism
even when the people want an alternative
to a liberal agenda that isn't working
very well
so then you see the pitting of
liberalism against democracy
which which the Liberals then attack
they attack democracy but they don't
call it democracy they wear the mantle
of democracy they say we're defending
our sacred democracy we're just
attacking the populists well what's a
populist a populist is someone who has
the people on his side well what does it
mean when you've got the majority of the
people on your side it means you're
standing up for the Democracy democracy
is nothing more than majority rule
intrinsically opposed and we see this
more clearly and clearly every single
day to liberalism it it true we hear all
sorts of attacks on our sacred democracy
like on January 6th the worst moment in
this or any Republic ever you want to
talk about an attack on Democracy what
they are doing what the Liberals are
doing in Colorado that the test run that
they've got to try to wield the law
unjustly to prevent a man who they say
is unelectable from being put on the
ballot because they know that he's
eminently electable because they know
that the people largely support him
that's the biggest attack on our
democracy that we've seen in a very long
time and we got to talk about it with
each other when you want to talk
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles is your cell
phone in desperate need of replacement
you know the signs short battery life so
you have to have a charger on hand
cracked screen that gives you glass
splinters it's time to put that old
phone to rest and upgrade to a 5G brand
new Samsung Galaxy from Pure Talk for
free get a free 5G Samsung Galaxy with
two day battery life edge to edge
display and Ultra strong Gorilla Glass
when you sign up for Pure talks
unlimited talk text and 15 gig data plan
for just 35 bucks a month plus it comes
with a mobile hotspot if you are not
using pure talk you are simply paying
too much get all the data you could ever
need for half the price of the big
carriers on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network right now head on over to
puretalk.com Knowles for your free super
durable 5G Samsung Galaxy when you
switch to Pure Talk use the cell service
that I love and trust and use myself
that is puretalk.com
make the switch to Pure Talk the
official Wireless partner of the daily
wire
so what do we do about it
what are we going to do about all these
problems
conservatives
in elected office and in the media and
everywhere in between are are pretty
good at diagnosing problems
but then they shrug their shoulders they
throw up their hands they don't have any
solutions
I think I've got a little bit of a
solution here it comes by way of my own
senator from the state of Tennessee
Marcia Blackburn who is uh warning about
the prospect of a government shutdown
and the government shutdowns happen
regularly these days but usually the
script is that the Republicans are are
eager or willing to shut down the
government and the Democrats don't want
to shut down the government what makes
this occasion different is that the
roles are reversed
the Democrats would like to have that
government shut down because it would
halt these investigations that the house
is working on and chairman Comer
chairman Smith chairman Jordan are
continuing to push forward to get this
information and to find out exactly what
the relationship is between Joe Biden
and Biden Incorporated and archives you
were just talking about archives not
wanting to turn over all of these emails
with the pseudonyms that Joe Biden was
using as he was vice president and they
want to get those so that they have a
record so they have that paper trail of
what the involvement was and of course
we know that they're continuing to get
bank records and the American people
certainly tennesseans Jason every time I
talk with them they want to know what
happened who was involved and for for
people that did things wrong they want
them to be punished
I certainly feel that way I think a lot
of other people feel that way too I
think one of the big frustrations with
our current system is that the bad guys
especially when they're liberals just
get away scot-free and there are never
any consequences for the clintons for
corruption under Obama and certainly for
the bidens
so that means that we got to keep the
government open why do we have to keep
the government open because in this case
a government shutdown would shut down
the investigations into Biden heading
into an election year and we've got a
lot of smoke when it comes to to Joe
Biden and Corruption and selling
American influence overseas and so we
should keep those going
I as much as anybody am sick and tired
of Republicans just chattering and
holding committee hearings and not doing
anything about it but it is a simple
fact
the only way today that you get anything
even resembling transformational change
is through the presidency and the judges
you don't get it by electing members of
Congress usually you don't get it by
electing Senators usually you can get it
in the state houses but that's just one
state out of 50 states so the way that
you get real change real laws are not
passed by Congress anymore they're
passed through the executive branch and
they're passed as under the guise of
constitutional or statutory
interpretation by the judges and the way
that you get judges is by electing a
president the way that you get the
appointed bureaucrats is by electing a
president and the way you elect a
president is by
electing a president in this case how
are we going to elect our president and
kick out their president the only shot
that we've got at it I'm not saying it's
sufficient maybe the Democrats have so
much power that it doesn't matter and
they can just rig the election like they
did last time and they won't be kicked
out of office but the only shot that
we're going to have at that is to bring
as much pressure as possible to bear on
Joe Biden and the Democrats and the only
way to do that right now
there are a few ways to do it in Private
Industry uh like shutting down the
liberal activist groups that that censor
the conservatives in the Public Square
like buying a social media platform as
Elon Musk did and opening it up to
conservative speech so that's happening
in the relatively private sphere and
we'll get to that in one second but for
ordinary citizens the only way that we
can do that to bring that maximum
pressure on Joe Biden right now is to
keep the investigations going and so
it's a matter of prudence and practice
we got to fund the government
I this is the first time in any of these
crises that I've said that the wise
thing to do is to go ahead and fund the
government but it is much more important
to try to take down Biden and try to get
our own Presidential nominee into office
than it is to quibble over a few
gazillion dollars when we're already at
a debt to GDP ratio over 100 percent
we've got to have more transformational
change than just nibbling around the
edges of the budget we need to throw a
wrench in the system now speaking of
throwing a wrench in the system
Elon Musk is threatening to sue the
Anti-Defamation League
for defamation
I love this story so much
been meaning to get to it for a few days
now it's just it's just been simmering
and it gets better and better and better
the Anti-Defamation League
is a group ostensibly founded to stop
anti semitism to stop hatred against the
Jewish people and smears against the
Jewish people that's not really what it
does I mean I guess that's part of what
it does but the Anti-Defamation League
will happily attack fellow Jews if those
Jews happen to be conservative or happen
to question the liberal narrative so the
Anti-Defamation League will happily
attack Libs of tick tock an Orthodox
Jewish woman because she doesn't toe the
party line and the Anti-Defamation
League will talk about things that have
nothing to do with the Jews whatsoever
just plain regular old left-wing
nonsense and the way that they do it is
by bandying around this accusation of
anti-Semitism just a specific version of
the race card which is the biggest card
you can play in America it's the worst
thing you can possibly be called and
they say hey if you oppose Hillary
Clinton you're an anti-semite hey if you
don't like Joe Biden you're an
anti-semite hey if you don't allow us to
censor your your platform we're going to
call you an anti-semite in fact the the
Anti-Defamation League
has sent out threats this is documented
we have letters threats to I think there
was one that they sent to Iceland uh but
they've done this a number of times
where they will say hey
I bet you sure wouldn't like it if we
called you a Nazi whether or not the
accusation is fair so you better toe the
line they'll threaten to lie about
people so there was a really awful
organization and Elon Musk came out
he himself having been defamed by the
ADL and said to clear our platform's
name on the matter of anti-Semitism it
looks like we have no choice but to file
a defamation lawsuit against the
Anti-Defamation League oh the irony
love it so absolutely go after the ADL
you should go after some of the other
groups too though it's not just the ADL
it's groups like right wing watch which
is a project of people for the American
way which is a one of the most
ironically named groups in America
because it is a handful of Elites for a
very Un-American way there are several
others out there where these groups
exist they're watching the show right
now and they try to clip out little
pieces of the show and get us all fired
and they try to censor people on on
social media my only
request as we take down all of these
left-wing sensor groups and we actually
wield political power because there's no
such thing as a neutral Public Square
there's no such thing as a neutral
political order we're gonna have to
stand for something or other we're gonna
have to push certain people out to the
fringes and I absolutely think we've got
to push these liberal sensors out to the
fringes my one request to Elon though is
as we take them all down please don't
take down my publicists at Media Matters
I have had a very good working
relationship with Media Matters for many
years now they watch my show every day
they're watching it now they clip out
some of the best parts of my show and
then I get to retweet them and they get
a lot more eyeballs on my work so please
take down the ADL take down right wing
watch do whatever you want but please I
have no interest in finding a new set of
publicists
now I also have no interest in going out
and replacing my propane tank which is
why it's such a great thing that we've
got cinch right now head on over to
cinch.com use code Knowles have you ever
craved a nice juicy barbecue meal with
the family so you go to the store get
all the groceries you invite the family
over or it's gonna be a fun time right
but then
you go to turn on the grill
and you're a propane tank is completely
empty
well that's where cinch comes in to save
the day cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane grill tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule and
requires no long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home you track the order on
the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you're grilling steaks or lighting up
the patio heaters on a cold night
cinch's propane delivery service ensures
that you have the fuel you need to make
the most of every moment go online to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just ten dollars with
promo code Knolls Canada WLS that's
cinch.com or download the Cinch app use
promo code Knowles to get your first
tank exchange for just 10 bucks it's a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it go
to cinch.com offer for details
old ways
more traditional practices regular old
religion
often scoffed at and demonized by the
libs
but not all the old ways
some old very irreligious things like
mystical practices of healing
are
opening doors for spirits
and demons you don't even have to ask me
even what the libs you're often talking
about
so is it all fake is it just BS are they
deluded
or is it something more my guest Jen
Niza
the Italian way would be Nitsa but Jen
explains exactly what happens if you
open that door and receive messages from
Beyond the Veil check out this teaser of
Michael and the former psychic
when I was a real psychic medium I
really wanted to help people I was told
I had a gift from God and that draws you
in right it must have scared you when
you discovered this ability I wasn't
scared until I started seeing scary
things and hearing scary things and
getting touched by demons
this episode Michael and the psychic it
was fine until the demon touched me is
on YouTube right now so be sure to head
on over there watch that and you can
check out the ad free unedited version
exclusively on Twitter at M knoll's show
and of course at dailywire plus my
favorite comment yesterday is from Co
Catholic gal oh there we go Colorado
Catholic Al who says you know the
episode is spicy when it's only 30
minutes long that's true when the show
opens up with the question is Barack
Obama a gay crackhead you know that in
order to accommodate our friends over at
YouTube who want to censor out anything
even moderately interesting or
controversial uh you know that we're
gonna have to trim that down and the way
to get the full show totally unedited no
bleeping no sensors no Cuts is going to
be RSS feed the Apple podcast Spotify
Stitcher Twitter eminol show and of
course daily wire plus so
Elon opens himself up by threatening to
sue the Anti-Defamation League
guess how the ADL responds you know how
the ADL is going to respond and the head
of the ADL Jonathan Greenblatt they're
going to say that any attempt to stop
them from censoring the American public
square is drum roll anti-semitism
were you seeking to have some kind of
either role at Twitter or any kind of
donations made or other things no I only
say that because there have been folks
who've looked at these situations and
felt that they were being you know
shaken down
look I think let let me be honest about
that right I think it is sort of
anti-Semitic Trope to suggest when
Jewish people Express a degree of
outrage over anti-Semitism that somehow
that's a Shakedown because Jews are
greedy
so the answer to the question is
obviously yes obviously Greenblatt and
the ADL
were seeking a role in censoring Twitter
the way that we know that Elon Musk
showed this is that ADL started its
boycott of Twitter ADL is largely
responsible for the drop in Twitter
Revenue after Elon Musk took over and we
know that the ADL launched its
anti-twitter campaign the moment that
Elon took over so the moment Elon takes
over nothing changes in the service of
Twitter over time he's implemented some
changes but nothing changes the moment
that he takes over but
in the ADL starts the
the Shakedown the ADL starts the
harassment campaign in order to do what
to just have fun on a Saturday afternoon
no in order to get a seat at the table
and have a role in shaping the content
of Twitter
and he says he's doing it in the name of
of stopping anti-Semitism or whatever
but that's obviously not I want to be as
charitable as possible maybe that's a
part of the adl's mission I'm somewhat
skeptical but certainly
the the mission is not merely that how
could you argue that trying to shut up
one of the most prominent Orthodox
Jewish women in the entire country is is
a good way to stop anti-Semitism it
would seem to be maybe an example of
anti-Semitism a self-hating sort of
anti-summit anti-anti-semitic campaign
I'm getting lost in the Inception of it
all
yeah that's what it is and so what does
he do when he gets caught his eyes open
wide he's oh no I didn't you're an
anti-semite for even asking that and and
this is of course the case accusations
of racism are always so
cheap they're so cheap including the
specific case of accusations of
anti-Semitism but but anything
anti-black anti-hispanic anti this anti
that other than anti-white you're not
allowed to even suggest that Prospect in
our culture the only group that you're
legally and culturally permitted and
encouraged to discriminate against an
insult you're not even allowed to bring
up the prospect of that but for any
other group it comes out and it's always
so cheap I remember
uh David Webb I brought this example up
before David Webb is black conservative
he was on the radio he was interviewing
a black woman who's a liberal and when
he was winning the debate she just said
well that's your white privilege showing
David
because it was radio and she didn't know
what he looked like and he just started
laughing he said uh you know that's not
gonna work on me lady
so what do we do in the face of this in
these cheap accusations of racism that
are totally disingenuous they're in bad
faith what is our response to that is
our response to care and to beg and to
say no please don't I'm not a racist to
some of my best friends or black Muslim
pygmies or whatever you know whatever
kind of
group is considered the most oppressed
no I don't think so you're not going to
convince them they don't care the
argument is not in good faith then is
the is the alternative to just be really
mean and cruel and discriminatory
against all sorts of different groups to
become what they accuses of it no I
don't think that's the answer either the
answer is
first
stop caring when they call you a racist
or an anti-semite or an anti-dissist or
a phobic or whatever just stop caring
it's not real they don't mean it
they just don't like you and they want
to shut you up so stop caring first of
all but then there is a flip side to
that too which is make sure that you
Orient yourself toward Justice and
charity
those are going to be a lot better
guides than anti-racism or being an ally
against the phobia or a thisism or that
just Orient yourself toward Justice and
charity and pursue the virtues and avoid
devices and Avail yourself of God's
grace and in all things act with Justice
and charity and then ignore the noise
who cares about that stuff speaking of
ignoring the noise
my man Mitch
cocaine Mitch McConnell himself
has been asked to step down as Senate
Majority Leader or Senate Republican
leader and
he says no
what do you say to those who are calling
on you to step down do you have any
plans to retire anytime soon I have no
announcements to make on that subject
but what do you say to those who uh I'm
gonna finish my term as leader and I'm
going to finish my Senate term thank you
I'm with Mitch man that guy wields power
great I don't care how old he is I don't
see a better alternative right now if
you told me there were some great
prospective Republican leader in the
Senate waiting in the wings who's going
to be right-wing and conservative and
okay great
but I don't really see that so as of now
I'm sticking with my man Mr cocaine
speaking of finding Alternatives there's
a video that was going viral this was
Emily radakowski who truly I could not
pick her out of a lineup I just saw this
lady going I thought she was a random
lady just like a random private citizens
go viral these days turns out she's
Emily radakowski who's a big model or
something and she was encouraging women
to get divorced
so it seems that a lot of ladies are
getting divorced
before they turn 30 and as someone who
got married at 26 has been separated for
a little over a year
32 I have to tell you
I don't think there's anything better if
being in your 20s is the trenches there
is nothing better than being in your 30s
still being hot maybe having a little
bit of your own money figuring out what
you want to do with your life everything
and having tried that married fantasy
and realizing that it's maybe not all
it's cracked up to be and then you've
got your whole life still ahead of you
um so for all of those people who are
stressed or feeling stressed
about that about being divorced like
it's a it's it's good congratulations
congratulations
congratulations the lady doth protest a
little too much me thinks really
terrible advice divorce is always just
awful in all circumstances it's terrible
and it's a fallen world and it happens
sometimes and the culture used to
greatly discourage it now the culture
encourages it the law encourages it
through things like no-fault divorce and
through the abolition of the meaning of
marriage by by redefinition and judicial
Fiat thanks to the Romantic poet Justice
Anthony Kennedy so everything is and the
whole culture of hyper individualism is
is aimed at destroying the family which
is destroying the country and it's
making everybody miserable you you know
I don't cite social scientific
statistics and because I think they're
bogus but when they support My Views I'm
happy to cite them
people have gotten much more miserable
you see this in self-reported rates of
happiness you see this especially in the
reports of rates of happiness for women
you see this in the prescriptions of
depression pills which have skyrocketed
for everybody but especially for women
you see this in uh the the average life
expectancy in the United States which
has declined because of debts of Despair
you see this in the major drug epidemic
and the suicide epidemic for uh white
men in their middle age in particular
people are really miserable and this is
coincided exactly with the sexual
Revolution at the center of which is
divorce divorce it's just and so we we
try to prune around the edges of the
sexual Revolution with this you know
fashionable ideology that YouTube won't
let me talk about or with the
redefinition of marriage or with the
lgbtq movement but it really comes down
to divorce and it's a political problem
not just a personal problem because it's
the fundamental political unit it's the
Bedrock unit of multiple people forming
a cohesive body on which you build
townships and counties and states and
ultimately a nation so one it's a it's a
political matter it's public you're
speaking to people you take a vow in
front of the public in front of a in
front of a minister in front of God and
we have the right to say something about
that because Emily radakowski's
selfishness or it just you know extreme
fatal supply of copium is uh not just a
problem for her it's a problem for the
whole country threatens the very social
fabric now before we go speaking of
women
I I do have to get to the story because
I teased it and it's not a long story to
get to it'll eat into mailbag a little
bit but we have to get to it Joe Biden
is very very old and now
CBS News has asked the awkward question
to his Vice President are you ready
so you're 58 now if you win the second
term as you and the president are
running to do he would be 86 at the end
of it The Wall Street Journal had a poll
showing two-thirds of Democrats say Joe
Biden is too old to run again
are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief yes I am if necessary
but Joe Biden is going to be fine and
let me tell you something
a little quick on the draw there are
common left not a great look first of
all she's obviously not ready to be
president though the government can
effectively operate without a president
now as it has been under under Biden so
I guess
she's as ready as anybody in that the
role of the individual in the office of
president has been diminished but not a
good look for Kamala
because you're in this case you're
supposed to say listen
Joe Biden is totally ready to go
uh there is no fear whatsoever that he's
going to drop dead or drop out of the
race or anything
so it's obviously when I accepted the
role of Vice President a prerequisite
for that is that one is prepared to step
into the role God forbid but I I'm not
but you see that question are you ready
yes
okay what what did you did you just get
a phone call did something happen I mean
um no Biden he's really good so people
champing at the bit to take over for Old
Joe in the election
even the Democratic primary that
election could get even more Bonkers
than it already is
now for some of the biggest news in
Daily wire history
[Music]
give you a little taste and then and
then we got you head on over to
dailywordplus.com subscribe sign up
today
finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbag the mailbag
is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com
for your free super durable 5G Samsung
Galaxy when you switch to pure talk I'm
running behind already I'm gonna fly
through these mailbag questions
hey Michael what advice do you have for
men and women who want to get married
and have a family but it hasn't happened
yet I'm in my mid-30s I've been on the
Catholic dating apps and attended my
local young adult groups all to no avail
it's pretty disheartening when the
desires of your heart are good and they
are not fulfilled especially when you
are getting older and wondering where
God is in your waiting season would love
some words of encouragement for women
and men experiencing this thanks for all
you do
a wonderful question and I'm sure a lot
of people are asking I I have so many
female friends in their 30s who will say
I really want to get married and it just
hasn't happened
and it's not because they're feminists
and it's not because they're liberals
and it's not because not because of
anything they're just great they're just
terrific but our culture is such that
it's much harder
these days to settle down find a husband
or wife it's hard on the guys too and
live a good life because of the
insistence that everybody just pursue a
career because of the insistence that
you find yourself and just establish who
you are before you meet somebody which
is completely bogus by the way it's
totally the opposite what you want to do
is grow up with somebody ideally
and and get married I mean just as
you're saying I want to get married as
quickly as I can
because you know when people are young
they're like putty you know and you get
two pieces of putty and you stick them
together and they fit really easily
together and then over time you know
they'll shape and in accordance with
each other
but if you leave the putty out and the
putty just kind of hardens into its own
shapes
then you try to stick those hardened
putty shapes together it's going to be
much harder not impossible plenty of
people do it but it's going to be more
difficult those are the difficulties
you're experiencing
you got to go to the places where they
are where the where you are likely to
find the people whom you would like to
marry I know this seems simple but
people don't do it so you say well I'm
on I don't like the apps or I'm on the
apps but the apps aren't working forget
about the apps apps are just a they're
the apps are a video game sometimes the
apps work I know people have gotten
married out of them but it's it's a
little game people are just swiping and
chatting it's you know
maybe not going to be the most effective
it's going to be friends of friends it's
going to be friends of family it's going
to be people at church if you're
fortunate enough to go to a church with
very young people at it I would
recommend the traditional Latin Mass
where the median age is eight probably
because of all the children people you
take the children out of it the median
age is probably 25 so I think that'd be
a good spot to go uh or professional
networking groups you know but with a a
political kind of a group a work on a
campaign for all you know you're joining
your local Republican Women's Club you
know what
well hopefully a different kind of
Republican Club where there are men but
I just mean go to places where people
who not only share interests with you
not just like the bowling league but who
share a point of view about the world
ultimately religious is obviously good
but uh even political even cultural even
that's where you're going to want to go
and it can happen fast
I know friends for whom having taken
that advice it happens fast okay next
question
hey Michael when I first became a
conservative
I think it's pretty safe to say that I
was viewing my conservatism through
capitalism
I was going to school with a bunch of
Keynesian people and socialists and I
wanted to prove to them that capitalism
was Superior to their model
I might have even considered myself a
fan of Ayn Rand
but as the years went by and I started
to think more philosophically
I started to care less and less about
capitalism or about economics at all
and nowadays I I kind of have the
opinion that capitalism is not
philosophical and so it doesn't even
enter into my political philosophy
do you think that this is a stance that
conservatives should take do you think
that conservatives should view economics
as something separate
from their political philosophy
um I appreciate your response thanks a
lot
no not as separate but as uh merely a
component part and not the most
important component your first part is
totally right I think you're still a
little confused in the second part of
what you've said uh yes it's true when
we are confronted with campus socialists
the inclination is to say well I'm a
capitalist
as though that were the alternative
capitalism is a word that was
popularized by Marx and Engels uh
capitalism is markets are good you know
uh economic growth is good but if you
make the source and Summit of your
ideology capitalism money then you're
you're no different than the Mammon
worshiping materialists that you're
supposedly fighting against
and capitalism is an ideology
is is not the opposite of socialism it's
just the flip side of it
but it's it both capitalism and
socialism make the same anthropological
error which is viewing man as
fundamentally an economic creature they
both make these fundamental
anthropological error reviewing man is
fundamentally individual the individual
is the basic unit of society rather than
the family is the basic unit of society
man is individual rather than as a
social and political creature so yeah as
an ideology it's wrong you don't want to
you want things in their proper place
when things are in their proper place
they can be wonderful but when you take
them out of their proper place and you
worship them and you make them an idol
then they they go very badly so no you
can't you can't separate economics from
your political view because economics
the way that we exchange goods and
services and accumulate wealth that's
part of politics and it's an important
part of politics but it's not all of
politics so what I would recommend is
no don't don't if you if you separate
economics then you take that out of the
realm of the political and you you say
that it's basically not even subject to
debate which is what the Liberals
classical and and modern want you to do
anyway no say no economics is totally
subject to political debate
and we want the best economic system so
we want markets that are thriving we
want economic growth because some
material Prosperity is necessary to the
more important aspects of political
flourishing but there are those more
important aspects and so you you need an
economy in service of higher political
goals and those higher political goals
are are going to be higher than money
next question
dear executive grassy Knolls I wanted to
mention that I saw that during your
member segmentum transition you have a
small quick scene of a light blue bowl
with some rusted keys inside and because
it's of your uh Catholic identity I
wanted to see if you would call those
your Catholic Church keys
your your Catholic Church Keys there's a
Church keys
because they're small and ornamental and
not very practical
[Laughter]
I have long discouraged people from
puffing on the Haitian oregano before
writing into the mailbag
but I am a sucker for a good pun and
that's pretty
because it's not like that you get it
those aren't the real keys to the
kingdom of heaven they're just a little
ornament for my show like a church like
a church it's a slightly labored pun
I wouldn't necessarily lead with that on
your borscht belt one-liners you know
when you're doing the Comedy Tour but
I enjoyed it I enjoyed it next question
Hey Dirty Mike Mr reality here I had a
question for you about Trump's poll
numbers so depending on which poll
you're looking at he's got 40 50 60
um support within the Republican party
uh I think you said many times he's
running essentially as an incumbent and
I would agree with that
um but when Joe Biden's poll numbers
come in at 67 being that he is an
incumbent we look at those as being
terrible because he's supposed to be the
one all the Democrats are rallied behind
um so we would consider anything less
than 80 90 for him uh absolutely
atrocious why are we not considering
Trump's the same way if he's essentially
running as an incumbent instead of
looking at it as oh he's up 40 40 points
on his Challenger that's great why are
we not looking at it as he's the
incumbent and he's only pulling down 50
or 60 percent this is absolutely
terrible numbers for him uh I just
wanted to get your thoughts on that
looking at these poll numbers for Trump
as if he wasn't incumbent instead of
just a regular person in the race thanks
great question the as if is the key here
because he's not really the incumbent
and so I think the error you're falling
into is just the flip side error of the
error that everyone else is falling into
which is everyone's saying well this is
an ordinary primary and so we're going
to conduct our campaigns as though this
were an ordinary primary it's not an
ordinary primary this is the first time
since 1892 that a president has run for
a non-consecutive second term
so he's running I've said practically or
effectively as an incumbent but not not
truly an income not really not even
essentially as an incumbent so your side
is you're saying well he's running as an
incumbent and so his numbers aren't that
great for it but he's not really running
as an incumbent for for starters because
there are 10 people in the field and Joe
Biden is running I guess technically
against two or three people but none of
them is really a serious Challenger the
closest is Bobby Kennedy and even he's
only at 19 20 percent
so Trump is running against DeSantis
very serious guy
the vague serious guy Nikki Haley
serious woman I mean whatever you think
about these people's chances we're
talking about Governors ambassadors
serious people with big political
machines behind them even now
so in that field with 10 people if
you're dominating with 59 of the vote
that's pretty impressive and may may end
up being decisive it would seem to be
decisive right now
this is why you can't
you can't compare Trump's position in
this Prime you can't compare the
Republican primary to anything you can't
compare it to an ordinary Republican
primary you also can't really compare it
to just an incumbent running for
re-election that's why I've said from
the beginning it is
basically unique it's happened one other
time in American history and so if
you're trying to use the rule book for
anything that we see with regularity
that's not ultimately going to serve you
very well okay the rest of the show
continues now
you do not want to miss it it's fake
headline Friday I need your help to
discern which is the fake headline among
all of the
Preposterous news stories that have come
out become a member right now use code
Knowles Canada wlas a check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]